is the protein bar you might be eating
for breakfast more of a sugar bar in her
new book the way we eat now author B
Wilson says people around the world have
diets rich in calories but poor in
nutrients she looks at our changing
eating habits and how it to improve them
B Wilson joins us first on CBS this
morning good morning I know we are
overfed and undernourished you say yes
what does that mean it means we've got
this huge surplus of calories in our
diets which in a way is a wonderful
thing it was something that our
governments quite deliberately planned
for after the Second World War when
people had suffered terrible hunger and
scarcity if you look back to 1950
half of all people on the planet were
chronically under fed now it's something
like one in nine that's a miracle that's
a sort of fairy tale about food but this
thing that they forgot in this focus on
quantity was quality and we're paying
the price now so you have people
suffering simultaneously from obesity
and undernourishment why do you say that
the protein bar is one of the enigmas of
our time well my question is why is it
called a protein bar not a sugar bar
that's one of the enigma
another enigma is why are there just so
many of them did you know and this
staggered me on the market in the u.s.
there are around 4,000 different protein
bars why do we and yet there's any one
kind of banana and it's not even a very
good banana I would say be that our life
is getting better you said but our diets
are getting we are clearly a nation of
fatty McFadden's we have more overweight
people than we've ever had and you said
it's not a matter of willpower it's a
matter of the choices that we make yeah
and but it's not just the u.s. I think I
mean we in the UK where I'm from we're
always beating ourselves up about
feeling like we're not French if only we
could be French we'd eat well and I
think you are the same in America my
sister lives in the US but actually it's
everywhere everywhere in the world is
suffering these sugary oily fatty diets
where basically all people are eating is
wheat and corn what do you want to do I
governments to do more I want these
girls to do more I think it's really
hard for any of us as an individual to
navigate our way through this
complicated world of you know in the
u.s. there are now four thousand
calories supplied for every individual
person
so to avoid overeating you've got to not
eat what's available but it's you see if
there's one thing we can learn how to
cook it's what I would say soup but my
vision of soup isn't just some kind of
watery TR to be boring bland thing I
mean hearty kind of chilies and stews
and things with lentils and chorizo and
spice and I just think part of why I
love soup is you can cook once and then
you are buying yourself a few days where
you don't have to cook because you
reheat it and you've got something
delicious and you can throw in lots of
good things before you that you can
maybe hide under something that's be
taste better
exactly it's my secret of how I got my
third child who was my picky one to eat
more vegetables it's one of my secrets
yeah so I think the soup is win-win-win
and it's hearty and it's delicious and
you don't feel deprived do you like I
mean a salad can be delicious too but
it's got that slight overtone of I'm on
a diet whereas a stew you were a curry
you kind of feel nourished thank you yes
I'm hungry right time thank you
lots of provocative stuff you've awesome
thank you thank you